[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes chers compatriotes aujourd'hui
dimanche 26 mai le peuple français a
fait entendre sa voix avec une force
inattendue
c'est une satisfaction immense pour tous
ceux qui n'ont jamais douté
pour tous ceux qui se sont battus et
n'ont jamais cessé de croire en la
france
cette mobilisation inédite dans une
élection européenne depuis plus de 25
ans témoigne d'un sursaut populaire
contre le pouvoir en place qui subissent
ce soir un véritable échec
j'adresse toute ma gratitude à
l'ensemble des français qui nous ont
fait l'honneur de leur soutien en
plaçant le rassemblement national en
tête de ces élections européennes
et tout particulièrement à ceux qui
venus d'autres horizons politiques ont
entendu notre appel au rassemblement
le peuple français a infligé ce soir une
sanction claire ainsi qu'une leçon
d'humilité au président de la république
qui a choisi d'engager toute son
autorité dans la campagne ce n'est pas
seulement la politique ou la personne
d'emmanuel macron qui sont désavoués ce
26 mai c'est également l'union
européenne qui à défendre qu'à défendu
le président de la république
l'union européenne ne peut plus ignorer
l'aspiration des peuples à la protection
à la liberté et à la souveraineté
elle doit désormais réorienter
radicalement sa politique économique
sociale et migratoires la poussée de nos
alliés en europe et l'émergence de
nouvelles forces politiques sur tout le
continent
défendant l'intérêt des peuples et des
nations ouvre la voie à la constitution
d'un groupe puissant au sein du
parlement européen
les français peuvent compter sur nous
pour les défendre et promouvoir le bon
sens au pouvoir je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]